new evacuations are underway in a deadly
and growing wildfire in Northern
California the so called car fire has
burned nearly 150 square miles and
officials say it's only about 17 percent
contained about 40,000 people have been
forced from their homes the fire has
killed six people including three
members of one family 70 year-old melody
Bledsoe and her two grandchildren died
in their home the car fire is one of
nine major wildfires in California
Carter Evans is in Redding north of
Sacramento where he spoke with Bledsoe's
husband Carter good morning good morning
this man's story is absolutely
heartbreaking he told me how he only
left his home not far from here on
Thursday for a few minutes to run an
errand it was about 15 minutes later
when he got a frantic call from his wife
saying the fire was at their backdoor I
was only going about 15 minutes when my
wife called me and said you got to get
here the fire is coming up the hill Edie
Bledsoe says he had no idea his home was
in danger when he left his wife melody
with their two great grandchildren ages
four and five I was talking to my little
grandson on the phone he's saying
grandpa please you got to come in
Hilversum fires at the back door I said
I said I'm right by honey just hold on
grandpa's coming but he says the road
was blocked with cars and the flames
stopped him from returning on foot other
died right there with them they're that
important to me
fire officials near Redding expanded
their evacuation orders Sunday more than
38,000 people have been forced to flee
their homes since Thursday officials say
the fire is now threatening communities
outside of Redding this time-lapse video
shows the fires intensity creating winds
strong enough to uproot trees at
Bludso's home is one of more than 850
structures that have been destroyed did
you get any sort of evacuation warning
nothing absolutely not a word nobody
told us nothing if I'd had any kind of
warning I'd have never ever left my
family in that house he said he didn't
hear any evacuation warning we're
looking into that Shasta County Sheriff
Tom
Senko says his department did tell
people living in Redding to evacuate
they're investigating to see if the
Bledsoe home got a warning call or a
door knob and the area's both before the
Bludso's home and after the Bledsoe home
there was evidence that notifications
were made for the door-to-door
notifications now authorities say one of
the people who was killed
ignored evacuation orders and
authorities are facing another problem
here as well looting so far three people
have been arrested including one man in
camouflage and carrying a loaded gun
according to police Alex Carter that is
a tough tough story to hear
heartbreaking gut-wrenching the Bludso's
family our prayers go out to them